the Joe Rogan experience first of all
limited meets written the hierarchy of
the plan okay okay today there is no
such thing as the Ku Klux Klan all right
there used to be there today there are
many Ku Klux Klan groups and they all
are autonomous they use the same name Ku
Klux Klan you might have the dixie
Knights of the Ku Klux land the
Confederate Knights of the Ku Klux Klan
the rebel Knights on on and on these are
all separate to Klux Klan groups they
believe in the same ideology they were
the same colors on their robes that
designate their rank they have the same
secret handshake this one is the secret
handshake just like honey I'll show it
to you later
yeah we'll do it later oh we can't tell
people in case honey shakes their hand
they don't even know I can't reveal
clans secrets oh okay seriously oh yeah
same passwords everything that passwords
yeah understand the plan was formed in
1865 at the end of the Civil War and it
was formed by by six Confederate
soldiers who were of Irish and Scottish
descent and what they did was they
borrowed the the rituals or similar
rituals and names and a mystery from the
Scottish Rite the Masons ran this
exactly precisely
don't they have dragons yep yep okay so
here's how the hierarchy works all right
so I have said over the years central
split apart into different splinter
groups a plan so and they are all
arrivals with each other if you see a
couple different plan groups out in
public they will hold a you know unified
front but behind closed doors they don't
like each other really yeah you know
we're real planning you know Darrell
wanna be plan competition another thing
because they may have been in the same
van at one time and something happened
somebody embezzled some plan dues or
didn't get promoted you know whatever so
anyway if you have a chapter
of your particular clan group in another
state or in multiple states you may then
consider yourself or your group to be a
national clan Roop therefore you must
have a national leader so oversees all
the states in which you have a chapter
of your a particular group so we call
our national leader the president and
clan terminology that person is known as
the Imperial wizard anybody who is who
is prefixed with the word imperial means
that person is a national officer wizard
being the top ayah so if you're a wizard
like a president an imperial clay Liffe
will be like a vice president and he
have secretaries treasurer's whole nine
yards and then the next level down would
be state the head of the state which we
call the governor that person is known
as a Grand Dragon anybody Grand is on
the state level state officer dragon
being the top of governor a grand clay
Liffe would be like a lieutenant
governor and then secretary treasurer
and then within the state who left
counties the county leader is known as
the Great Titan anybody on the great
level doesn't look as on the county
level within the county you have
districts what they call clavin's and we
would call a district leader a mayor a
councilman aldermen that individual is
known as a as an exalted Cyclops so
exalted Cyclops arrests them you would
say sir exalted Cyclops yeah Wow that's
hilarious
[Applause]